Верховна Рада ухвалила новий закон про засади
функціонування державної мови.
Люди, які зібралися під стінами парламенту,
вітають один одного. Мета закону -  захистити
право українських громадян отримувати інформацію
та послуги державною мовою.
Цей закон, на думку багатьох учасників мітингу,
є символом перемоги над радянською русифікацією України.
Більшість людей говорять, що спілкуються вдома українською мовою.
Але коли вони приходять на роботу
чи в сферу, де їх обслуговують,
наприклад, ресторани або подібні місця,
то до них звертаються російською.
А коли до них звертаються українською, то ті не відповідають українською
Державна мова в Україні - українська.
Це прописано у 10-ій статті Конституції.
Але за всі роки незалежності закону про державну мову,
де було б чітко прописано, як саме
має втілюватися ця стаття Конституції, так і не з'явилося.
У нас зараз ніякого захисту немає. Зараз будь-який чиновник
може розмовляти будь-якою мовою.
Ніхто не зобов'язаний українською мовою на рівні законодавства звертатися.
Закон передбачає, що в державному і публічному секторі,
зокрема в лікарнях, транспорті, у ресторанах та кафе,
перукарнях тощо мають розмовляти українською.
У кафе та інших місцях обслуговування можуть
переходити на іншу мову, якщо цього забажає клієнт.
У театрі, кіно, книговидавництві головною мовою стає українська.
Газети та сайти, які мають іншомовні версії,
обов'язково повинні мати й українську.
На телебаченні та радіо 90 відсотків ефірного часу
має бути українською.
Юрій з Харківщини з цим не згоден.
Мені не подобається, що в російськомовних регіонах
нав'язують українську мову.
Чому російськомовне населення Сходу та Півдня
мають читати пресу українською, дивитися телепрограми,
новини українською мовою? Чому в них немає вибору?
З Юрієм погоджується пенсіонерка Олександра Василівна.
Вона переконана, що українська мова достатньо захищена законодавством.
А закон занадто політизований на тлі боротьби проти російської агресії на Донбасі.
Для чого це? Щоб зайвий раз роздратувати народ?
Це не соціальне питання. І сьогодні воно не стоїть на першому плані, розумієте?
Однак для таких, як Павло Островський з Дружківки, що на Донеччині,
це першорядне питання. Він ще в 2012 році  в Донецьку
проводив акції на підтримку української мови.
Він вважає, що такий закон про державну мову
вкрай необхідний україномовним мешканцям Сходу та Півдня України.
Людина, яка говорить українською в цих містах,
часто позбавлена вибору.
Вона не має можливості купити газету українською,
бо в кіосках 90 відсотків видань, якщо не всі 100 - російськомовні.
І в сфері обслуговування,
і в інших сферах домінує абсолютно російська мова.
Закон про державну мову може розділити суспільство,
застерігають його противники.
Прихильники ж переконані: навпаки - країну об'єднає державна мова.
А у політиків більше не буде підстав маніпулювати мовним питанням
у своїх політичних цілях. Мовляв, тепер в Україні
захищена і державна мова, і мови національних меншин,
які регулюються окремим законом.
А на приватне спілкування і релігію
закон і так не розповсюджується - тут кожен і далі сам вирішуватиме,
якою мовою йому зручніше спілкуватися.